30 Days to a better business.
So I got this idea in the morning, I was having a shower.
What if I created a free course, where I would make a video every day, with a tip,
to help you guys as entrepreneurs and then be available for an hour
on Twitter afterwards to answer the questions and to discuss and to help each other out?
So say I'm making a video, it comes out at 9 in the morning every day.
You watch it and then from 9 to 10 on that morning I'm there answering questions on Twitter.
You can write to me whatever you have, we'll go through the material on the video
and help you in that moment and give you something you can do today.
"Here is your task for today to build your business", free video
and me for an hour after, available on Twitter answering your questions.
I want to know what you think, because I would have loved that when I starting out.
I would have loved that resource and opportunity, but I want to know what YOU think.
Because that's crazy work for me!
And I'm not getting paid to do it and I'm happy if it's going to have an impact.
I'm happy to do it for you guys, but you need to want it!
So here's the thing, here's the test:
If I get 100 comments on this video from people saying that they want it,
100 comments for "30 Days to a better business", with a tip every day
and me for an hour afterwards.
If 100 comments are on this video, I'll do it. For free. For you guys.
If we don't get the comments I'm not going to do it because you don't care enough.
So let me know, leave a comment, if you like it enough enlist your friends.
We'll see what happens! 30 Days to a better business!
Believe!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community